[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace norte américa hoy
desde ciudad de mexico nuestro primer
tema es el referendo revocatorio de
andrés manuel lópez obrador los
ciudadanos de este país están convocados
a las urnas el 10 de abril para decidir
sobre su permanencia en la presidencia
explicaremos la trascendencia de esta
consulta y la polémica que la envuelve
también ante stewart hemos el resurgir
de la ciudad de mexico como capital
cultural de iberoamérica tal como fue
reconocida en 2021
[Música]
desde el inicio de su gobierno a lópez
obrador o prometió que se sometería a
referendo revocatorio envió su
iniciativa al congreso y quedó aprobada
en noviembre de 2019 los ciudadanos de
al menos 17 estados debían reunir dos
millones setecientos mil firmas para
solicitar la consulta una organización
afín el mandatario junto más de tres
millones
el instituto nacional electoral es la
autoridad responsable de organizar la
consulta con las mismas características
que una elección presidencial por ello
dispondrá de casillas en todo el país y
ya capacita a los ciudadanos que
recibirán las papeletas y contarán los
votos el consejero electoral roberto
ruiz encabeza la organización y explica
la trascendencia del ejercicio y precisa
que se requiere para que el resultado
sea vinculante la relevancia creo está
en que estamos inaugurando en nuestro
país estos mecanismos de democracia
directa de democracia participativa a
nivel nacional ya existían estos
esquemas a nivel local pero no a nivel
nacional y es un reto para la autoridad
electoral 40 por ciento de las personas
que están en la lista nominal es decir
las personas con derecho a votar
tendrían que participar y dentro de este
número de participantes
tendría que haber un pronunciamiento de
la mitad más uno
manifestando que se tendría que revocar
el cargo el referendo ha estado envuelto
en una controversia quienes más lo
promueven son el propio lópez obrador y
sus seguidores argumentando que es hora
de la democracia participativa en
contraste hay quienes advierten que el
mandatario y sus partidarios desvirtúan
la consulta al presentarla como de
ratificación y no revocación como marca
la ley además que es un gasto inútil
pues la constitución fija el término del
cargo hasta 2024
es muy importante para nosotros dejar un
precedente para que a partir de este que
es la primera vez que en nuestro país
tenemos una consulta para poder revocar
o no un mandato pues que a partir de
este momento pues ya los siguientes
presidentes o presidentas que vengan
pues también se sometan a las consultas
no vamos a quitar el presidente nosotros
que somos pues yo creo que la asociación
los promoventes más fuertes a nivel
nacional pero que si queremos que la
gente participe que la gente se entere
que hoy ya existe un mecanismo que hoy
ya es un derecho para todas y para todas
nosotras pero nosotros hemos dicho que
este proceso va a ser recordado con un
revoca fraude porque se está
desvirtuando el espíritu de la figura
del derecho ciudadano de la cesación
constitucional del encargo de un
presidente repúblicas y hoy por hoy la
oposición mexicana no está pidiendo la
sensación del presidente incurrir en un
gasto su naturaleza parece completamente
inoficioso porque entonces no tiene otro
propósito que tener algún índice de
popular el presidente después de una
larga pugna de lópez obrador y sus
partidarios contra las autoridades
electorales con motivo de las
restricciones de difusión y el
presupuesto asignado para realizar el
referendo este se hará y aunque no
participe el 40% de los votantes el
presidente sostiene que si la mayoría
decide que se vaya él se irá
[Música]
y así como la vida política cobra auge
en el país la ciudad de méxico- reactiva
su riqueza cultural el festival de
primavera es ejemplo de ello después de
dos años la vida cultural ha renacido en
ciudad de méxico el público ha asistido
a 20 foros y plazas para disfrutar de
más de 50 espectáculos gratuitos de
teatro circo danza y mucha música desde
bolero y jazz hasta electrónica y
mariachi pronto en france 24 les
estaremos llevando toda la información
gracias por acompañarnos en enlace
norteamérica desde ciudad de méxico soy
mario carbonell y mi compañera en cámara
lizette romero hasta pronto
[Música]